hey francis do you like books uh only
when they have pictures all the
waterproof ones i can take in the bath
with me all right well for those of you
who can read and enjoy reading satire in
particular we have just the book for you
what's satire shut up the book is called
woke fragility it's a brilliantly funny
takedown of robin d'angelo's white
fragility and woke culture more
generally it will keep you amused
through the small wee hours as
civilization collapses all around you
it's satire as it's meant to be allowing
you to laugh at things the powers that
be have now deemed off limits we all
know that comedy now is more toothless
than joe biden after he's removed his
dentures this is what you need to hit
the funny bone in these demented times
and it's received an average of 4.4
stars on amazon if you've already read
work for agility then tired moderate
also has two other books out the little
book of work jokes and scary stories to
tell the world in the dark a woke parody
of scary stories to tell in the dark
i'll read that book which one the little
one
find his books on amazon and enjoy a
satirical book that's funny and playful
what are these terrible views that you
hold and that you express that that
caused you know students to be
protesting about you on campus and so on
um well it's mainly about categories um
so i don't believe that trans women are
literally women i don't believe that
trans men are literally men
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
frances foster i'm constantine kissing
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant guest today has
been in the news quite a bit recently
she is a british philosopher and writer
who has recently left the university of
sussex where she was a professor
kathleen stock welcome to trigonometry
hi
thanks for having me it's good to have
you i imagine there's been quite a time
for you and we'll talk about that before
we get into that just tell everybody a
little bit of who you are how are you
where you are what has been the journey
through life that leads you to be
sitting here okay well i'm originally
from scotland um i am or was a
philosophy lecturer at the university of
sussex which is in brighton in the south
coast of england
and for most of my career i was pretty
uncontroversial unless you specialized
in very um
abstract theories of fiction uh
and then i got very controversial very
quickly because i started speaking out
about
gender identity and proposed legal and
policy reforms and the costs as i saw
them for women and girls in particular
and lesbians
i'm also a lesbian
so it was relevant to me
um and then uh things
went on from there and i have been uh
hounded out my job
you have and uh as i say i'm sure it's
been a difficult time
but can we before we get into what's
happened to you can we start by
some of these controversial opinions the
trans issue we've explored quite a bit
on the show
um
what are these terrible views that you
hold and that you express that that
caused you know students to be
protesting about you on campus and so on
um well it's mainly about categories um
so i don't believe that trans women are
literally women i don't believe that
trans men are literally men i think the
categories of women and men are useful
conceptual categories
to pick out
adult human
females and males respectively
i also think that that has
consequences for policies
because biological sex is really
important in a number of ranges of human
sorry across a range of human
domains and
medicine is one sport is another
single sex spaces are really important
because of the
relationships between men and women in
terms of uh
susceptibility to sexual assault
so um
i that's it really i think so you can't
change sex right trans women aren't
women trans men aren't men
um gender identity is not more important
than sex and gender identity certainly
shouldn't um determine things like
access to sporting teams
same-sex spaces
um
resources and so on the
you you're talking a little bit sort of
academic language but
you're not in the sense the
conversations that we have on the show
i kind of like that but i think for just
a normal person who's tuning in going
who's this professor who's got whatever
basically what you're saying is
people with male bodies shouldn't be in
in female sports people with male bodies
shouldn't be in female prisons people
with male bodies shouldn't have access
to other women's spaces
and you can't change your sex just by
saying words
yeah right i mean those things it's
whether you've got a male or a female
body makes a difference to all sorts of
other things
um females are on average smaller weaker
um slower
than males uh in a world in which most
people are heterosexual you know males
have a sexual interest in females
as we know sexual assault statistics
tell us that um
females are much more likely to be
sexually assaulted than males and
they're much more likely to be assaulted
by males than by females so we a
progressive society puts in
at a minimum
like places where women and girls get
undressed
or sleep gives them their own spaces or
tries to and uh the current orthodoxy
that's coming out of lgbt organizations
is that that is somehow prejudicial to
trans women
and that and not just trans women but
anyone who any male who says they feel
like a female should have access to
those spaces so yeah
now to me kathleen what you've just said
just smacks of common sense
why has that become so controversial
well i mean that's a good question i
think uh there's multiple
causal
background factors here um
but in in universities it's
controversial to say the things i'm
saying
that's partly i think because of the
disproportionate influence of certain
academics in the humanities
coming out of philosophy gender studies
um who have quite radical utopian
style views about what gender is and the
ideas that we need to just clear
everything break down all these
boundaries
the even the biological um
boundaries between men and women are
really social not natural so they that
means they're mad they can be changed
and they're malleable
um so we really we should progressive
society should be enacting policies that
disrupt those boundaries rather than
entrench them so you know that that is
never going to fly
outside universities but you'd be
surprised or not surprised to know that
in universities quite extreme
ideas can flourish there's also the
influence of
lobbying groups in the uk like stonewall
it's
historically
famous and rightly so for defending gay
rights but it's now got a new agenda in
the last
five or six years which is about gender
identity affirmation of gender identity
and stonewall is in
nearly every british university
and also a lot of other uk institutions
as well so
with stonewall pumping out propaganda
that says
um
you should get rid of any reference to
sex biologically in your policies in
your resources in your spaces
and also having all this stuff about
bullying and harassment and how talking
about sex or is
automatically um
[Music]
suspect and if you get it wrong you know
if you misgender somebody then that's
bullying stuff like that it's not really
surprising then that universities
what people young impressionable people
in universities have come to stop
believing all this stuff so that i think
that's the kind of story of how they got
there and it's also in schools
you know and the teachers are agreeing
um
so it's a bit like a kind of religious
indoctrination program and it's worked
really well and kathleen what was the
moment for you because we all have a
breaking point with this stuff with with
me it was when
after brexit people were demonizing old
white men as being racist stupid thick
etc
and my father was an old white man who
married a woman of color back in the 70s
that upset me that was a moment where i
thought no enough's enough now when was
that moment for you
um i mean it was in 2018
and it was um
i mean it
i think i can't say it was one moment
but there was just a series of things in
2018 which i just noticed
one was that the government the british
government were consulting on whether we
should change
getting a gender recognition certificate
which
changes your legal sex they were
consulting on whether that should just
become purely a matter of self-id just
saying i feel like i'm female signing a
form basically paying a small amount of
money
at the moment it's a kind of gatekept
medicalized process and it has certain
conditions built in but stonewall and
other organizations were heavily pushing
to go to self-id
and i was
looking around for the academics who
would be saying hang on a minute
there's a lot of problems here if you're
just going to open up this
sort of privilege really to
anyone who says they feel like a woman
and that will give them all sorts of
access to um
spaces and resources and so on um
potentially so we need to think about
this and yet it was a wasteland you know
there was just nobody really talking
about that and anyone that outsider
universities were trying to talk about
that
um
then they were being shouted down and
called they were said they were
transphobic i mean i'm actually
exaggerating because there were a few
people in universities trying to talk
about it but they were having an
obviously terrible time
so um that started to really annoy me
because i'm a philosopher
and i my training tells me that i'm
supposed to be able to talk about
things
argue use reasons evidence and that we
i'm allowed to disagree with people
without it being a personal
um flaw
so that annoyed me and then the other
aspect i suppose is that i am gay and
part of this new orthodoxy is that you
can identify your way into lesbianism as
well so
you know males with
male bodies and penises calling
themselves lesbians and being accepted
by
lgbt organizations as lesbians when the
whole point of being a lesbian is you're
not interested in
male-bodied people with penises
so
it just seemed like upside down world
that this was being pushed by gay or you
know traditionally um
gay rights organizations is just
absolutely bonkers still i think is
bonkers
and
we'll touch on on the lesbian on the
lesbian thing because one of my best
mates is a gay woman and she was talking
about this stuff
right before it became a mainstream
issue and i was saying to a simi what
why is it that europe's so upset and she
was saying that there are lesbian spaces
which men would then
come into say i might identify as a
woman
and then they would they would just have
to be accepted yeah
i mean
one thing i think
back certainly back then that a lot of
people didn't grasp
because the stereotype of a trans woman
i think for many people is somebody
who's had surgery
taken hormones
and is probably
attracted to men so probably gay
originally like what a gay man who then
has surgery and hormones but actually um
quite a large percentage of
trans women are heterosexual and or
bisexual but they're attracted to women
they're sexually attracted to women
now
if you are a trans woman and you
identify as a woman
and you're attracted to women
then um
you know it would be presumably it would
be quite challenging to your own
identity if you went after straight
women because they're straight and
they're supposed to be interested in men
so lesbians are the group that get the
attention because it's supposed to sort
of somehow follow from the logic of who
they are they're attracted to women so
what they must be attracted to trans
women because trans women are women it's
this kind of weird calculus
that goes on and i think that's why
lesbians early on
were aware of this pressure and and sort
of the weird consequences of this logic
earlier than most people because it
doesn't really affect straight women the
same way and it doesn't affect straight
men
or gay men that way
although sometimes now apparently trans
men will
try and convince gay men that they
should be sexually interested in them
because they're men um so yeah i think
lesbians were sort of on to the issues
earlier
can i ask you something i mean it's
gonna sound a bit primitive this
question but
francis and i sometimes you know we've
talked to about this issue a lot and
every now and again we just look at each
other and go do you not think this is
just [ __ ] mental
like like what you've just had to
explain do you know sometimes just like
pinch yourself and go really yeah really
this is the conversation where to write
a book about it i know material girls in
a very good book it is right
yeah well yes i mean i did not have made
the joke before but i did not see my
lifetime sort of contribution to
philosophy be to be writing a book that
explains there are two sexes and the gay
people exist
you know but here we are um
i just think it shows how susceptible to
flashy sounding
ultimately
mad ideas human beings can be in the
right circumstances so
i think it's sociologically interesting
how
so many of us seem to have gone along
with this despite the obvious um
terrible consequences for children for
for gay women for um
for women in sport and so on we seem to
unable to put all these um
pieces of the puzzle together so it does
show
it takes away the hubris of
supposedly rational people that we are
where we are but yes it is as as i met a
woman not that long ago and she said i'm
from the east end we call this [ __ ]
nuts
i mean
it's hard to disagree at this point
which brings us very much onto look
we've charted what three the three of us
how bigoted we are with our evil
opinions so let's talk now about your
situation you were talking about how in
2018 very few people in academia
particularly felt able to speak out
against this
what is it that you did that caused all
of this
assuming that you did anything well i
didn't do anything other than say the
sorts of things i've just been saying
alongside uh other things which i also
believe are true which is that trans
people should be protected in law
and policy and if if um possible and i
think it is possible we should find
creative ways to meet their needs too
but but what we can't do is just
collapse the categories of women and men
legally
because they're there for good reason
because women and men are different in
reality and nothing we say in language
or in policy will change the fundamental
differences between men and women
and then the impacts that that has
so all i said was things like that
but
there's this i suppose it goes along
with the um
the sort of [ __ ] nuts element of it
that if somebody is saying something
that's [ __ ] nuts then they've got a
really strong interest in stopping any
rational scrutiny of that so alongside
extreme transactivism goes this kind of
cult-like
structure which says anyone who
disagrees with us is a hater
they could only be coming from a
position of of bigotry and dislike of
trans people which is absolutely not the
case in my case or
really hardly anyone i know
across the gender critical movement and
of course the gender critical movement
includes trans people who also say this
is [ __ ] nuts and you know hang on a
minute not in my name
so um
yeah i don't know uh so you started
saying all of this
i started saying that yeah i wrote some
blog pieces and then i kind of graduated
i started being asked to write things
for publications i mean originally it
was just on medium
then i did talk
public talk a place an organization
called women's place which is a
grassroots feminist organization raising
these issues on the left
and
you know colleagues at sussex students
um colleagues in philosophy across the
world uh
members of the public
a lot of them just kind of
went into action to try and start
getting me either fired or get me to
shut up basically because uh obviously
what i was saying was threatening to
their position and by saying trying to
get you fired or trying to get you shut
up what do you mean by that specifically
well i mean in 2018 um
the times ran an article
where
i mean i didn't know anything about this
until i read it in the times but they
had been in
facebook groups of um
trans activists who had
been
working out how to use i think they were
like saying usually let's use equality
act to get her um accused of a hate
crime and you know let's um lobby the
vice chancellor so so from right from
the start there was kind of organized
moves to um
get me either censored
or fired i suppose um
students have done various things at
various times you know there's internal
complaints systems in universities for
good reason but um they can be used
fixatiously and they won't use vex
agency against me so i was put through
quite long prolonged internal
investigations uh for things i'd said
online that were perfectly fine as it
turned out and i was exonerated of all
charges but you know it's a
the process is the punishment to some
extent um
protest at my talks i've been
d-platformed
a couple of times
big petitions against me
uh using the internal mail of sussex to
put out various communications that are
highly prejudicial
and mistake my position
i mean that's the thing
my position is never accurately conveyed
by these people it's always conveyed in
the sort of most lurid
um uncharitable way and they'll seize on
tiny little aspects and blow them up to
big massive meaningful
things
um
so it's been a bit of a battle really
just to kind of
deal with all that because it just comes
at you
kind of relentlessly
and why are you kathleen
well i mean it's coming not just coming
at me he's coming out anyone who says
the sorts of things that i say i don't
think i'm special in that respect
um i think the only thing that perhaps
makes it more intense in my case is that
i was at sussex university which is in
brighton and brighton is the heart of
the portland of the uk yeah um i mean i
liked brighton or did like brighton
i used to live there even but um
it's it's you know it's got a long
history going back to the 17th century
of gay people uh being there and um
in recent times it's you know
queer culture central in brighton and
lots of young kids there
who came there for that reason and they
went to sussex for that reason so i
think it was probably important
to shut me down even more important to
shut me down because i was quite
symbolic
that i was saying all this stuff whilst
at sausage university
i mean
i'll be honest you kathleen when i first
came across your story and i was reading
about it i was like good on you good on
you for speaking up good on for saying
your truth and then or what is the truth
i should say and then i saw that you did
it in brighton and my first thought was
she's [ __ ] mental
yeah i know
well yeah yeah but i mean i i wasn't
gonna not say it because i lived in
brighton yeah um
it's just an accident i got a job at
sussex i could have got a job at like
hull or somewhere maybe this wouldn't be
gone the way it did but um
i mean i i that talk i referred to was
for a woman's place and that was in
brighton and that was in 2018.
and i did i did think this is a bit
mental why you know
that was
because the um previous women's place
meetings the one before that had a bomb
threat and the one at oxford had been
really aggressively protested and that
you know at that point
there wasn't the public understanding of
our position at all
so i think it was just really easy for
gen members of the general public to
think they must be transphobic why else
would they be going on about this like
so
it really felt like a hostile
environment and we were giving uh doing
this event in brighton
um and it was quite um intense
you know what i find odd about all of
this kathleen is that
at the same time as government
organizations are ceasing to take advice
from some of these activists
that are lobbying for easier transition
and all of this other stuff at the same
time that clearly people are starting to
realize that they'd gone too far we're
still having conversations like in your
case where uh people you know when you
go on the mainstream media there was an
article in the guardian this morning
misrepresenting what happened to you
right like i don't understand how we
have these two simultaneous things
happening on the one hand people are
realizing that maybe in the name of
diversity and inclusion and whatever
else and being compassionate which i
think is what motivates a lot of people
of course to support this position we
just lost sight of the truth and what's
important
while at the same time people like you
are being demonized right alongside that
that doesn't make any sense to me well
it's not the same people in every case
obviously but um i think what it shows
is how embedded this ideology is in our
institutions that um people are still
finding out about it
or they're finding out that what they
thought was a kind of harmless
inclusive
kind stance has repercussions for other
protected groups
or for free speech or for children so
um
it is really well embedded and so it's
going to take quite a lot of um
sustained
uh action to get out basically and
i don't think we're even
halfway there yet because there's been
some focus on stonewall recently but
there are other organizations in britain
that we need to focus on like mermaids
which is the child
centered
gender identity uh
affirming organization
who regularly misuse suicide statistics
to scare parents into
going along with medicalisation of their
children
and that you know there's a whole set of
issues we could go into there but it's
you know we need to think about that we
need to look at it um the public needs
to know about it
um
and just keep getting the message out
and partly
the problem is or has been
that there are media organizations that
just won't talk about it or won't talk
about it fairly or objectively now
that's starting to change hopefully
because the bbc have left stonewall
diversity champion scheme
um but other media organizations are
still in there
and the guardian has a long way to go
what a surprise
but
one thing i'm always fascinated with
your story is you're getting all this
flack
you've got you're turning up at work
every day you're getting complaints made
about you which
are not based in any type of fact
whatsoever
they're just done as a way to
essentially
wear you down drag you down
why didn't you give up why did you not
think you know what life's too short
i've got this wonderful career at a
great university
i could just shut my mouth and i could
just carry on with my work why didn't
you do that
i mean i don't really know obviously
except that there's just something
that is
i've never yet reached the stage where i
think the cost to me is too great
um
i think the issues are really important
i think they're really really really
important like sex non-conforming
children
their bodies are being irrevocably
changed their fertility's being
irrevocably compromised you know because
of this idea that there's something
inside you that is much more important
important than the material facts about
you and that somehow it's innate as
opposed to changeable so yeah those
things keep me
that issue and the
women's space issue
keep me hooked in and i just think part
is my philosophical brain that will
not accept inconsistency
you know
even to my own detriment to some extent
i just can't have it so of course i go
through periods where i'm like oh this
is just too much
and then i kind of
you know make a mental resolution to
kind of step back
but then i read something that annoys me
i get back right in again yeah and then
you get back so
let's go back to the story you're
working in sussex it's
2020 2021 what was the moment for you
where you thought i can't do this
anymore
oh right well um
so
term has terms started
this academic year in on
end of september
um
and there'd been a few things you know
this year that happened already that had
really
upset me at the time
but you know i came back
to campus everyone was back on campus
because the covered um
sort of distancing had stopped at sussex
so it was all face-to-face teaching
and um
the first two weeks
didn't feel great i knew that
i was
you know a bit of a pariah on campus i
could tell
um that i was
but then this campaign started um
the first thing i knew was
i went to the loo and there were
stickers on the back of the toilet door
um talking about the transphobic [ __ ]
that comes out of kathleen stock's mouth
and obviously that's not very pleasant
so
but i had no idea as part of a campaign
i actually thought that was just a
one-off i thought it was sort of
relatively emboldened student
um
and then the next day as i walked into
um
work there were posters all the way over
the main entrance with my name on them
saying um caffeine stocks are transphobe
we don't pay um
nine thousand pounds in fees for
transphobia fire caffeine stock
um
so that was um
quite
difficult to say the least for me um i
felt very very exposed and
frightened i suppose uh definitely
distressed but anyway i went home and
realized that there was this now this
manifesto up online
full of you know quite intimidating
language telling readers to get really
angry to get angry stay angry or to um
you know angry enough to do something
about it we've [ __ ] had enough
um
she's a spiteful bootlicker
uh
transphobe et cetera et cetera and
saying until until she's fired you'll be
seeing us around
and then um
they'd taken pictures of this guy all in
black with a sort of dress like antifa
kind of stuff holding a big sign saying
uh stock out with flares going off
standing on the university of sussex
sign and that was on the website as well
and from then on it just you know every
day there was a new action um so they
took all the posters down they all went
up again the next day
graffiti started going up um there was a
about 10 of them arrived on campus
unannounced one day
all with signs saying stock out fire
stock
um
and then and then leading up to this
open day protest where about 100
people
were um
across the campus the main sort of
square of the campus whilst parents and
potential applicants were coming
in they were all standing there with
their marks on and their banners
actually some of the banners apparently
said quits quit stock so clearly you
know it's like either
i'm saying i should be fired or
basically trying to get me to quit which
obviously they did
eventually so um
so all of that was
[ __ ] obviously
um and i was teaching from home at this
point
on zoom
because the police had told me not to go
onto campus
and
had opened an investigation into it
um why did they do that why do they why
did they say you shouldn't go into
campus
well because i would say i mean
it's a clearly intimidating harassing
atmosphere and sussex is a campus
university set in the sussex downs
it's not like you can just sort of slip
in and slip out again once you're there
you're
you know every 10 to 10 to the hour
everyone moves lecture theater there's
just hundreds of people streaming across
campus including me had i been there
um
it would have exposed me to potential
risk so we're concerned about your
safety is what i'm getting at yeah i
mean the language of the manifesto is
clearly aggressive
um i'm not saying that everyone involved
in this
was aggressive i actually think lots of
people that got involved especially in
the big protest probably
had no idea what they were doing he said
it seemed like quite a fun day out but i
think that the ringleaders of this
um
are very focused on me
quite obsessively focused on me
and calling me you know spiteful
bootlicker or whatever um
in the language they were using and the
imagery they were using and the idea
that that their sort of their website
was called anti-turf sussex so it's like
antifa so i'm the fascist and they're
the antifa
and that's the dynamic they're trying to
set up right so
yeah i was definitely not going to
wander around on campus and i'm not a
martyr
the reason that i hone in on this point
because what you what you mostly
described sounds like a football manager
at the end of their a tenure you know
stock out quit all of that stuff and the
argument that people
have made this is going to sound cruel
and uncaring but i'm russian so it's
part of my culture
is you believe in free speech these
people were expressing an opinion about
you they didn't like your views they
didn't want you to be around they
expressed that and you weren't
physically assaulted no as far as i know
right
so
isn't that their free speech to to say
stock out
well i mean
if they were just saying stock out then
obviously that would be their free
speech but they weren't just doing that
were they um
i mean it's not i'm not
it's not up to me to decide where the
borderline of
legal definitions of harassment
fall but
as far as i can see the police think
it's conceivably within that
i think universities are interesting
places because
yes there is such a thing as academic
freedom and in fact
i think it's very important and i'm on
record as saying that but it's also a
workplace um
and it was my workplace right so
i think that the people that
at this point strategically move to the
free speech defense i always think it's
quite interesting because these are not
traditionally people that give a [ __ ]
about
but
all of a sudden they do
and yet um they're also the people that
quite often will complain about things
like twitter pylons or
in fact were actively complaining about
me saying things like
trans women are male
generally speaking not you know now this
is posters with
my name on it you know every single
communication is a direct reference to
me i'm not an elected politician i don't
represent a large corporation
my speech is within the law and
demonstrably within the law and moreover
i'm a moderate
so
i don't think that's acceptable
um
and i also think it sends a terrible
message to anyone else who thinks like
me within the university so it's
chilling of free speech so we've got
these clashes or alleged clashes
um when free speech gets shut down it's
usually by other speech
right you know it's not because that's
how human beings communicate through
speech
so um we need to be able to work out
what the difference is between the kind
of speech that ultimately shuts speech
down and the kind of speech that doesn't
and as far as i'm concerned posters
flares
saying i should die alone
etc that falls on the side of that's
chilling
and how would the university of sussex
were they supportive to you
i think once the um
once the
student harassment campaign started they
became supportive of me
yes
so you ended up
leaving in spite of their support rather
than due to lack well yeah i mean the
final straw as documented is that the
uni my the sussex ucu
branch which is the university and
college union um
at sussex then put out a statement which
is basically in support of the students
and
condemned
the institutional transphobia of sussex
allegedly which by which they could only
mean
uh supporting me um so at that point
i mean that's the problem if it had just
been a bunch of students going rogue
i could probably have handled it if i'd
felt
um that there was some sort of clear
understanding this was unacceptable
behavior but there wasn't there's no
clear understanding amongst my
colleagues that this is unacceptable
behavior a certain group of colleagues
think it's absolutely brilliant behavior
and went online immediately to say how
they applauded it so once you've got the
grown-ups
cheering the children on as it were um
i just you know it's just not the
environment i want to be in anymore
hey constantin do you like christmas no
in ussr we cancelled christmas and we
had lenion fest instead hosanna we
celebrated glorious leader and rewrote
story of jesus to make it better really
yes in our story three wise men were
killed and gifts men for jesus
redistributed to glorious workers of the
soviet union jesus was put in gulag for
having wrong opinion as we call it in
russia happy ending
right well if you do want to celebrate
the festive season then there's only one
way to do it grab yourself a ticket to
our final live show of the year at the
leicester square theatre on saturday
december the 11th yes it is discussion
with one of our favorite guests aisha
she is almost as good philosopher as
vladimir lenin
yeah exactly our two previous shows sold
out completely and this one will as well
grab your ticket now before it's too
late click on link below during interval
there will be special entertainment i
will ride bear with my shirt off i
didn't realize we were going for that
demographic mate oh yes we are ex
was there any communication between you
and some of the people who were coming
after you because you know we've had
jordan peterson on the show we've had
our friends brett weinstein and heather
uh on the show
and i know that they they
when they were essentially forced out of
their campuses
they made attempts to communicate with
the students in jordan's case i think he
went outside and tried to talk to them
and they shouted him down in bretton
heather's case they ended up with
students roaming the campus with
baseball bats looking for them
were you ever in in any dialogue with
people who were trying to when you put
it like that i can't think why it wasn't
yeah um no
well
way back in 2018 i um
wrote an email kind of
as a standing invitation to all
philosophy students which i then put on
my website saying if anyone wants to
discuss with me at any time come to my
office hour you know here's my position
and i've always made it clear that i
would not expect students to agree with
me
um you know i will put stuff on the
reading list that disagrees with me i do
that anyway for anything i'm teaching
and most philosophers do
so um
i've kind of communicated that way
through the standard
pedagogical
uh methods
and i've gone out of my way to make it
clear that i'm open to dialogue and
occasionally people have taken me up on
that
but no once they started
i'm not i'm not you know
i'm not mug i'm not like what am i
supposed to do i'm not like i don't
think i'm some sort of messiah figure to
go out there and like
overcome this
these are the people running this are
wankers and i have no desire
to talk to them yeah well look people
are going to accuse me of victim blame
and all sorts of things but it's my job
as an interviewer to have the
conversation
to prod at the seams of what we're
talking about because i guess the real
question underpinning this line of
discussion for me is
where is the line between their free
speech
and
harassment intimidation things that are
actually against
you know the law or against what a
workplace should tolerate do you see
what i'm yeah i understand i mean that's
a big that's a standard philosophical
question
yeah and where do you think that is when
did they cross the line with you do you
think
well
i mean i don't i'm not i don't i'm not
necessarily that clear in my own head
about the where exactly the line is in
my experience in
philosophical thinking generally lines
are blurry and there is no
line and there's a i'm a sort of
aristotelian i think context is always
relevant
but um that's quite a controversial
position yeah
controversial position
is important
for some philosophers it really isn't
that important so
i don't think he was talking about
philosophers but it doesn't matter
but um
i think from the minute they put them on
well the posters
i've
personally that crossed my line you know
i think again there's a sort of failure
of empathy um defensively from my
critics
who just can't i think they would not
put up with that in their own workplace
was it directed at them but they expect
me to
but i also think the manifesto the
language of the manifesto
is threatening and it's not you know
rational debate or even
sort of vociferous disagreement it's
actually they i don't think they even
know what i think on half these issues
is just get her out it's more like get
the witch out right so we're not i don't
think people should be in any doubt that
this is some sort of like
you know academic dispute gone a little
bit wrong
there's nothing academic about this
there's something pretty primitive about
this it's like get that heretical figure
out of our environment you know people
are holding up signs saying we were
meant to be safe here and yet nobody can
explain why i made them unsafe and i've
been teaching trans students
you know without as far as i know
perfectly appropriately and
professionally throughout this whole
thing so i'm not making anyone unsafe
and the whole thing is based on a
massive
misrepresentation of me my character my
views there's no evidence ever really
provided that's gonna
you know convince anyone who isn't
already ideologically up to their neck
in it so
yeah i don't know what to say i mean
it's not up to me either to convince
people that this was
you know take if you don't think if you
look at this stuff and you think this
isn't a problem all right i can't i
can't change your mind on that for me my
line was crossed and i was going part of
the reason that this story is so
powerful is
because when i look at it it's for me
the story of
a person who stands up and says
something which is
rooted in fact rooted in science common
sense something that we all know
a tiny minority of people then felt
emboldened to go and destroy them
and we are where we are and that's what
we all fear we all fear it everybody
feels this fear now in society whether
they're going to get dog-piled on
twitter whether they're going to have
their careers their reputations
tarnished etc etc
it's very much a story of our time isn't
it i think so yeah and you're right
about the tiny minority i mean it's not
representative of the majority of sussex
i know that and i know most students
don't think like this
even if this even amongst those students
who disagree with me on the specifics
they wouldn't think this was the right
way to go about it and i think most
colleagues are horrified and yet
in every institution
um partly because of social media um
a small number of people can have a very
loud
and powerful
chilling effect
and you do become frightened um
social ostracism is a very powerful
weapon like i think it's probably
hardwired into us to fear it right
because being a part of a tribe
strengthens you
um and being
out on your own clearly weakens you
so yeah people fear it well in the in
the primitive condition being ostracized
from the tribe would mean you would die
100
and so of course we fear it and by the
way i have a lot of empathy for your
situation again i was asking the
questions to get to the bottom of the
argument
no i but i feel it needs to be said
because
even people who watch this show which is
people who are intelligent and are
approaching this conversation from a
sort of more enlightened place even they
sometimes oh you said this that we've
become very black and white in society
which i think speaks to your case
as well
um
and i think francis is right and you're
right when you say that this is
really you're the head on the spike
to tell everybody else
not to do this
don't speak yeah and to some extent i
have um
you know i did leave so i do
um
worry that i've effectively made it
easier for um similarly motivated people
to act this way
in other universities
i mean academics are in this
quite strange position
which they always were in but i think
it's supercharged by social media and
the ability of students now to small
numbers of students to organize really
quickly
um
so we are there to basically say what we
think that's built into our job
description academic freedom is
um a value is written into the mission
statement of every british university
um
but at the same time
universities are now in competition with
each other for students so they're
trying to like massage their images and
make themselves look as
attractive to students as possible
and the students are right there you
know
um in your face so it's a bit like a
school although it's not a school and of
course they're adults but they're young
adults and they're still finding their
way in life a lot of them so it can be
quite a volatile mix
um if you're saying something that
some numbers of students really object
to
um so i think that's a that's an
interesting aspect of this it's not
you know now in it in a way through
leaving i've become freer
to say
like i just said that i thought the
ringleaders were wankers
and i do but i couldn't really have said
that i don't think my pedagogical
role but i'm not
a teacher anymore so i can say that but
i think so i think we've got people left
in universities to get to my point who
are
increasingly exposed to this and this
has set an example
which so i hope basically universities
have to help
these people they have to support them
in in um
in
expressing controversial views but
didn't they do that with you they
supported you and still you were forced
out they supported me
quite late on
right
i mean
i think if you're going to
i think for a university to support
someone in my position
ideally
you would identify quite early on that
they're a risk and that they are being
isolated and you would move various
structures in to psychologically support
them you would also look at your social
media policies now this is where you
might say ah like this is an incursion
to free speech again but you know when
you've got
academics sometimes more senior to you
um
on social media saying
this person is a bigot for saying this
like no evidence no argument just
transphobe bigger
they're like a racist they're like an
anti-semite etc churning that out to
students and i think universities should
look at that and say okay our social
media policies should not allow
people to just defame
others in the institution
so
and that's not just the sake of it it's
because it has this effect on the whole
institution becomes paralyzed because
they're frightened that it's going to
happen to them
these are complicated
interactions between the speech of this
law and the speech of that law i do i'm
not underplaying that at all it's really
a mess to sort out but it is a problem
we have to address
the thing that i i just can't get my
head around it this entire hashtag be
kind while screaming epithets at the
opposite side wishing to shut them down
effectively effectively destroying their
lives let's just call it what it is it's
just trying to destroy trying to destroy
their lives it's trying to destroy their
lives yeah yeah but but how does that
work well it works partly because um
kindness
is not a transparent value is it like
there's a saying you've got to be cruel
to be kind you know so like how exactly
you are kind
should be an open question
but
kindness as a value tends to be
adopted by
really narrow-minded people who
interpret it in ways that sort of are
self-serving basically so it's like a
fig for their own will to power
basically so i found it quite amusing at
various times to see that the my biggest
most vociferous
aggressive sneering critics usually have
like
empathy
in their bios
um but the whole um
i mean again a complicated story but
activism social justice activism is now
being
rewarded professionally in universities
like
you can say oh i'm on the equality
diversity and inclusion group in your
promotion application and that will be a
good thing and you know there's all
these little power structures being
folded into the bureaucracy that allow
individuals who are not empathic or kind
to use that language to cloak their own
ambition or envy or
desire to get ahead or whatever it is so
yeah
be kind be inclusive
these are very nebulous
um
vague vaguely defined terms that can be
interpreted in lots of different ways
can't they well once you've decided that
your opponents are nazis then the kind
thing to do for society is to destroy
them exactly
now here's a question which is quite
controversial and i'd love to get your
opinion on it which is
how much responsibility because i'm all
about responsibility should the gay
rights movement take for this when it
comes to things like stonewall they did
a lot of great work in the 70s 80s and
90s
when gay people as you know better
better than me
discriminated against we've now come to
this point where gay marriage
widely celebrated and now we've come
to where we are now
how much responsibility do you think the
people like stonewall etc should take
for this
well i don't think that the original
founders of stonewall should take any
responsibility for what's happened now
because they're not involved anymore i
mean
these organizations have a rolling um
kind of membership as it were in the
trustees and
the management
but the pres and actually you know
one at least one of the original
founders simon vanshaw has been very
very critical of the direction that
stonewall has taken
but the current incumbents and the
recent ones like ruth hunt i mean
they've just
set a bomb under lgbt solidarity because
they have tried to redefine what being
lesbian and gay is in terms of gender
identity not
attract attraction to the same sex as
you
and they did that and then wrote hashtag
no debate
so
lesbians like i just said were being are
being told
you
you know if you don't consider trans
women as potential dating
partners
you are prejudiced you need to think
about that you know you need to examine
your prejudices like no the whole point
of being a lesbian is that you don't
fancy men males that's the point so um
now that's the the ordinary person's
understanding of what gay is but that's
not the understanding that stonewall has
anymore
um
so they're in these multiple
contradictions
and yeah they're like i say because of
their influence in british institutions
they are very responsible for a lot of
this they they really tran you know the
t-shirts trans women or women get over
it
from uh
i don't know what 2015 onwards uh trying
to change the law around sex by
deception that's what one thing they've
been trying to do so that
it's not a um
a crime or in any way
wrong not
to divulge your own sex
in sexual relations with a partner
that's in one of their manifestos
so
you know that raises all sorts of
questions people want them to know who
they're going to put sorry to interrupt
just to put it into the ways that people
can just see what you're talking about
if you go out on a night out and you
meet another woman
and she happens i [ __ ] hate this you
meet another person who claims that
they're a woman and has a penis
and you go doesn't tell you and doesn't
tell you
like that's that's what you're talking
about
that would so if that proceeded in
certain directions that would count as
um
sex by deception i mean there are laws
that prohibit that and that you are
supposed to disclose
um
your sex and that it's um there are
there's precedent cases where people
have not disclosed their sex they
pretended to be of the opposite sex in a
sexual encounter and when the victim
found out
um
that they were very traumatized because
that's not reflective of their own
sexual orientation and um
what i'm saying is just one example of
stonewall's
sort of massive radical ambitions that
in
the 2015 document of vision for change
which has sort of set the agenda for the
next um
so many years
changing the sex by deception laws was
one of the things that they said they
wanted to do because they want to
protect the privacy of trans people is
how they put it so they're putting the
privacy of trans people construed as not
having to explain
who you are
uh
and biologically
above
how the partners might feel
about that interaction that's just one
example of the sorts of things they were
trying to do so yes i do hold stone
responsible and then they said hashtag
no debate
so it's just really really uh i don't
even know if they knew how radical
the things that they were saying were
let me ask you another possibly even
more provocative question because i was
struck how at the very beginning of our
interview you were talking about
biology you were talking about how men
and women are different you were talking
about the consequences of that
and
those are things i agree with entirely
and i've always agreed with but those
are the things that there was a period
of time at least until the trans issue
started become coming to the fore where
there was a portion of feminists who
were very much attempting to undermine
those very things
you you sort of i'm you're i'm happy for
you to challenge me on that no no i
think you're right
what do you make of all of that
so
i think um
i mean i do talk about this a bit in in
my book but there was a time in feminism
in the um
in the late 20th century
where um
some feminist academic feminists in
particular would try and argue that
womanhood was not the same thing as
being female
and they weren't doing that with any
kind of trans inclusivity in mind they
were doing that because they were trying
to avoid
fruitlessly i think um
the threat the political threat of what
they what was called biological
determinism which is this view that your
biology sort of determines what your
aptitudes in life are and you're
like whether you're good at housework
education whether you should stay home
and look after children
and that was you know that's a
conservative position that still exists
in lots of places but they thought they
could get sort of avoid that threat by
saying aha but women aren't female
they're not
contingently female but you know it's an
accident womanhood is a social role that
isn't necessarily attached to being
female though quite often the pain
forces us to do this because that's what
men
so that that was one part of it that
were radical feminists who said that um
that exactly that that sort of the the
femaleness itself was a construct and
maleness were constructions of
patriarchy and then there was the sort
of um post-structuralist version through
judith butler that said that
heterosexuality was the
constru it was a social construction of
patriarchy or of um heteronormativity
and you know i mean
i've now moved definitely moved into
academic language but the idea that is
that you know the things that evolution
basically hardwired into our species are
not in fact hardwired there
they're socially produced and because
they're socially produced we could
change them
if we wanted so there's nothing natural
about males and females and there's
nothing natural about heterosexuality
being the dominant sexual orientation
for humans
they would say
so insofar as feminists
went along with all that then yes
they did uh
maybe they didn't foresee that it would
go this way but they laid down some of
the groundwork for this now because it
is the idea that everything's inherently
fluid and flexible
except when it's innate you know i mean
it never makes any sense really but the
reason i bring it up kathleen sorry to
interrupt is i think to me that's a
textbook example of why you should never
pursue political advantage through lying
that why it's important to look at the
facts even if they are uncomfortable or
unpleasant to you in that moment because
it will end up being used against you at
some point well i mean i'm sure it's
true you shouldn't but i don't think
they thought they were lying um well i
mean they they thought they did believe
that everything was socially constructed
they had arguments that led them to
those conclusions the arguments were
terrible
but they believed them well they ignored
the data but it also had they did have a
story about how the data was not the
thing they should be paying attention to
because science itself was a
construction you know on this view so
everything's a construction so they can
become very skeptical about when people
say oh
um
evidence has shown us because they think
that that's
political
as well and politically constructed so
i i mean i
i know what you're saying and i agree
with you but i do also don't like the
collapse um it's part of the
polarization
in this area to
you know people could be wrong without
lying
it's true it's true i look and by the
way i'm not actually trying to make it
like
the feminist got at all i just to me
truth is a sacred value it really is
they think they're they think they're
saying something true too i know but
you've got
the problem is that yes they thought
they were saying it but the system they
created presupposes the non-existence of
truth by default if everything is if
everything is the patriarchy then
nothing is the patriarch and nothing is
true
okay well
go you're going a bit fast but yeah i
will concede that they they would think
that notion of truth itself was suspect
mind you if you say it's sacred it makes
it sound like you're
adopting kind of crazy religious
attitude towards it and that's not
necessarily great
oh well it's either
interesting philosophical argument i'm
not uh
do you mind if i carry on with this no
no no you're correct
no so
so what i mean when i say it's sacred is
i mean that it should never be
sacrificed for other things in political
discourse at least we should never say
that something is true but because it's
unpleasant uncomfortable difficult it
leads us down past we don't want to go
down we should therefore pretend it
isn't true do you see what i'm saying
yeah i see what you're saying absolutely
i mean i do think i'm not sure i agree
with you i just don't know exactly where
i stand on there but i know there are
plenty of truths that are sort of
uninteresting boring and then there are
some truths
so this is where i probably differ from
you but there are some truths that i can
see why
if we focused on them exclusively
um and particularly with certain sort of
interpretive slants they would cause a
lot of harm so
given the con given the the wider
context like i said everything's in a
context so you can't just take one
particular truth you have to look about
how it's going to be disseminated who's
going to hear about it how they're going
to interpret it what else is going on
and they you know
truths can be co-opted into politically
detrimental strategies and that's why
people are worried about the things that
i say but it's um
i don't think you're going to find an
all-or-nothing position on this i think
it's quite obvious that we need to talk
about biology quite obvious because it's
just so important across a range of
domains
but that's why i'm making a point of
this kathleen because i think
that is where the trans issue comes from
as you just said it's the desire to
achieve
particular political objectives or
social objectives
by
okay maybe they the people who went
after you thought that they were on the
side of truth and right or whatever
right
but you've got to you've got to get to a
point where you're not willing to
sacrifice what is objectively true for
the sake of your political ideology it's
less the case when i'm you know i agree
with you about focusing on on a
particular truth that paints a picture
that you want to paint what i mean in
this case is sacrificing truth
deliberately
in order to achieve a political aim i i
mean i i i don't disagree with you i
talk in my book about fiction because i
think it's a fiction that you can change
sex um and i say well look there's a
role for fiction in people's lives at an
individual level we pick up books
we go to the movies we imagine ourselves
we daydream you know people fiction is a
totally normal natural part of human
life and for some people who have
profound gender dysphoria it's
helpful to engage in the fiction that
they are of the opposite sex but what
where the problems come in
i mean problems come in at the range of
children
um which we can talk about separately
but where problems come in is where
we're compelled institutionally to
to basically go along with that fiction
and at that point truth has been
sacrificed and and then we have all the
problems that we are now seeing
and we are where we are where truth is
being sacrificed what do you think
is going to be the future for
universities and academic institutions
there's a big question there i don't
know i mean
i think um
it's an interesting time and i want to
see how they respond to this sort of
problem
my worry is that they just don't see
that they've got a problem because
they're in a kind of crouched position
and
a lot of the values in in the name of
which this is being all being prosecuted
as we've said are things like kindness
inclusion equality and they all sound
great
um
so the danger is that university
managers who are not deep thinkers quite
often at the best of times
think well how could this be wrong and
and basically the whole hr section with
sector within universities is becoming
moralized in very narrow directions
through lobbying groups through
benchmarks through kite marking schemes
through you know
all these kind of um
boxes that hr want to take in order to
establish that they are
a good place to work and a good place to
study so um i think academic managers
really have to
get a handle on how that might be having
an effect on what could be permissibly
said within those institutions what
ideas may permissibly be had and
explored
and ideally just
get any kind of overt moralization out
of management and out of the bureaucracy
because it will just free up a lot of
space because we've got like vice
chancellors participating in stonewall
um
activities you know that just sends a
message
right across the whole university that
gender identity is to be affirmed
because that is stonewall's position
kathleen it's been an absolutely
brilliant interview before before before
you ask the last question okay i've got
a couple more a couple more quick ones
not the philosophical ones actually but
more
uh sort of societal and also personal
what have you learned from this
experience
and what should we learn as a society
from this experience that you've had
what have i learned i've learned so much
about human nature that's for sure
um
i've learned well i've learned that um
i've learned what solidarity is
in the sense that um
women in particular
across the uk
um and grassroots organizations have
supported me and kept me going and if it
wasn't for them i could never have done
any of this but i've also learned what
solidarity isn't
uh
within institutions
and i've learned that it's really
solidarity is really important if if
basically
other academics had come out much
earlier and stood beside me and either
said we agree with her because lots of
them do or at least she should have a
perfect right to say all this
we wouldn't be where we are but
basically ostracism the mechanisms of
ostracism destroy solidarity and those
two things
you know are antithetical to each other
so with more demonstrated solidarity
amongst people there would be less
ostracism
but ostracism will thrive
where there's no solidarity if that
makes sense so
i've just learned the importance of
basically standing up and saying
yeah i'm with her or him
at crucial times because it sends this
message
and if people don't do that then you
really are on your own
well i've said this a lot a lot of the
time you know the cancel culture thing
only really works because they go after
people who are vulnerable
i say many of the same things that you
say and no one goes after you because
they can't do anything to me well
exactly and now i'm out of universities
like i said i i
am aware of that that
i mean i'm not saying that i'm not still
really annoying but what can they do now
because they've done it so they've shot
their bolt but while i was there and you
know it's not a coincidence they go
after women far more than they go after
men because there's plenty of men within
universities even that say
um some of the things i say anyway and
don't get half as much flax so yeah the
whole we're all set up to work out i'm
sure that's hard why too who's the most
vulnerable person here is the weakest
who can we pick off and we know
um we can judge so yeah that's why it's
crucial for men to get involved actually
and i think
a lot of men think that they shouldn't
that it's not their business that
somehow they haven't got any skin in the
game and they don't want to be
accused of mansplaining
i say
come in
we love a man
kathleen thank you so much for coming on
it's been a pleasure obviously you know
i've been through a
sort of
public
thing much smaller level than you and i
know how painful and difficult that is
so all credit to you for conducting
yourself with the calm
and the sort of gentleness as well that
is needed not to inflame things and just
to get your message across and to be
reasonable and to be calm and to be
rational really really i commend you for
that thank you and thanks for coming on
the show we've got just one more
question for you before we go to our
locals questions which is what is the
one thing we're not talking about but we
really should be
i don't know i'm afraid i i think i've
said it all okay all right that's
fantastic kathleen if people want to
find you online where is the best place
to do that uh well i've got a website
kathleenstock.com which basically just
lots of links to lots of interviews and
stuff i've written and i'm on twitter
doc's stock
with uh
2ks at the end
excellent and people should get your
book which is material girls yes i have
a book material girls and it's been out
stock but it's been reprinted so it's
now back on back in the show back in
stock yeah uh good uh i'm sure you've
heard that before look uh thank you so
much for coming on and thank you guys
for watching and listening at home we'll
see you very soon with another brilliant
episode like this one or raw show all of
them go out 7pm uk time and if you want
your trigonometry on the go it's also
available as a podcast take care and see
you soon guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button so that you never miss
another fantastic episode and if you
believe that the work we do here at
trigonometry is important support us by
joining our locals community using the
link below